well I'm waffle that a pun well it
wasn't a very good pun if you I'm kelcie
this is my friend Annie and today we're
trying another Instagram famous food we
are in Irvine California and we're gonna
try out the Instagram famous sweet
comforts and their waffle pops it's a
waffle on a stick okay I'm ready
[Music]
hi my name is Kevin Bobby I own sweet
comforts home of the waffle pops what
are we trying today the waffle pops it's
a classic Liege waffle just on a stick
our batter is all made from scratch it's
infused with pearl sugars then from
there we put it into our custom waffle
iron so you can't find this design
anywhere else and we dip it into our
cookie butters the top it with drizzle
it amazing waffle pop on a stick from
there well is your reaction to the insta
gotten baton it's always kind of
humbling you know it's just a dream come
true really you know for my partners and
I can't wait to try let's do it they
smell really good they smell like
chocolate mine's like straight-up churro
I got the bam bam it's dipped in white
chocolate with a white chocolate drizzle
Verde pebbles and a cheesecake bite
churro crunch it's kind of like a churro
shaped like a waffle I was like
breakfast are you ready for this I'm
ready
good it's very soft I really like the
crunch added from the cereal on top it
reminds you kind of of your childhood
the cereal you know there's cream cheese
drizzle on it it complements it so well
for the toppings of the dip it like went
into the little groups of the waffle
this is dangerous I can eat like three
of these that chocolates still warm and
gooey and melty you can really taste the
cheesecake bites which is like a fun
creaminess
it looks really indulgent for for some
reason it doesn't taste and dalton
showed no emotion but this is the most
emotional I've ever seen Annie so much
texture so many fun shapes I could not
have expected this okay so good it
tastes like a warm hug it'll warm
breakfast dessert hug I'm a pancake girl
but I think I would change my stance for
this waffle a pancake on a stick that
would be terrible that would be that
doesn't sound good
I don't think you could do this with
like a copy paper what do we knock I can
change